I'm very ready let's do this okay
welcome everybody glad you all hope you
all had a good spring break and glad you
could make it back for this talk which
is not at our usual time we usually have
this conference on Thursdays but when we
have special guests we change the date
and we do have a special guest today dr.
Mohamed Sayed molasse from Indiana
University who I guess he said it was
okay since this is being webcast I can
mention to the world that he's here
interviewing for a faculty position in
de maiz and also with the division of
Nephrology in the department of medicine
dr. Millis is originally from damascus
syria where he obtained his medical
degree at Damascus University he then
came to the United States and did a
residency in internal medicine at
Indiana University he completed that
he's board-certified in internal
medicine and then entered a fellowship
in nephrology and is on the verge of
completing that and also at the same
time has been in a clinical informatics
fellowship at Indiana as well so he's
being he's meeting with folks from both
informatics and nephrology in the
department of medicine his talk today I
don't have a title here I'll let him put
up the slides so you can come on up and
take the wheel for the kind introduction
so thank you all for coming so I am
going to add to what Bill just mentioned
I finished the nephrology fellowship at
this point and I'm board-certified so
I'm just gonna be finishing up my
informatics training by the end of this
academic year
so just for me to understand about my
audience here by a show of hands who are
the MDS here beautiful do we have a
nephrologist here in the room okay
hopefully they are watching the
livestream okay
and then the rest are probably computer
scientists IT folks predominantly I
would think so
what I'm trying to do this talk is try
to give a little bit for everybody
so because of the nature of the topic
there are multiple aspects that are very
important when we talk about the M or
base phenotype in EMR stands for
electronic medical records so some
elements will be quickly reviewed just
for the sake of time to get to my actual
research work but then if any of you
have any questions we can get to it in
more details later on so like Bill said
I am I did my medical training in
Damascus University in Syria when it
used to be a functional country it came
to the United States in 2010 did my
internal residents medicine residency
and then clinical nephrology fellowship
and now I'm finishing up my clinical
informatics training so the outline is
going to be the following elements I'm
going to briefly overview what EMR based
phenotype think is just to make sure
that we're all speaking the same
language and have the same understanding
at least to a good degree and then I'm
going to go over a case study to
highlight some of the clinically
relevant aspect to EMR based phenotype
things we're going to go over some
challenges and then I'm going to go over
in much more details and focus on the
National end stage kidney disease
program and then the research work
in that domain so a quick slide just to
briefly review some of the terms that I
will be using over and over I found that
this is helpful in my previous talks so
I kept it on yes are these in stage
kidney disease that's when somebody has
kidney disease to the point where they
need dialysis therapy which is the use
of some machine to do cleaning of the
blood to maintain life the u.s. RDS is
the United States renal disease system
that is sort of the hybrid of
Informatics and nephrologist they are
the body that collects data analyze data
and publish reports about the
performance of dialysis units CMS that
goes without explaining standard.i
mortality ratio I'll get to it in more
details but that's basically a
standardized metrics of the mortality
over dialysis unit most of you are
probably familiar with most of the stuff
on the right side of the slide
structured data as data that we can
immediately or with minimal
pre-processing can be inputted in
analytical processes machine learning is
where we use predictive models without
specifying predictors the predictors are
discovered by the Machine natural
language processing is where you we use
it mostly for text and they M are based
phenotyping world is where we take raw
text and then create structured elements
out of that that we can use for
downstream analytical purposes recall
and precision in the clinical world
those are sensitivity and positive
predictive value so what is the M R
based phenotyping well the term
phenotyping it came from the phenotyping
that is G knowing in proteomics based
and that's the right side if you look at
a simple sequence of nucleotides which
says the T a C and G that's what
constitutes all of the human genome
through multiple processes of
translation and transcription and that
generates proteins protein then fold and
get together and then go to the distant
target where they achieve a clinical
effect that represents the state of the
patient
that don't get captured in our EMR
systems through big databases the the
concept of those databases are zeros and
ones as we all know so why do we need to
note I think well we do know that we
need better ways to identify cohorts for
trials we do need that we need to have a
better sense of the cohorts multiple
clinically relevant elements such as
their demographics their comorbidities
and other things that are relevant for
trials baseline characteristics is only
one of them you can refer to that as
Table one in any clinical trial paper
determining endpoints for clinical
hypothesis testing that's also one of
the things where phenotyping is very
important one of the very common example
is looking at CV outcomes when we do
clinical trials CV outcomes a composite
between strokes M eyes heart failure
hospitalizations all of these are end
points that can be phenotypes from an
informatics perspective and then as we
many of us know them the design
implementation of clinical decision
support tools using phenotyping has had
a lot of attention in recent years
particularly in the management of
chronic medical diseases as an
outpatient but also has some role in the
inpatient world along the same lines
there's also role for phenotyping that
goes into the management of the
administrative processes of health care
and other roles as well but those are
some of the key clinical highlights of
the role of phenotyping so phenotyping
has two major ways broadly defined
rule-based and computational the
rule-based one one is where rules are
generated based on a number of elements
that you can then apply to a whole
cohort and you get your phenotype so you
can say I will define diabetes as
everybody who has hemoglobin a1c above 7
so that would be a rule so a
constellation of elements such as vital
signs billing codes laboratories and
medications are some of the common ones
those are some of the common structured
ones but then you have natural language
processing which is a method to generate
structured data that also can be used in
rule-based approaches the computational
approach is a different one it's where
you're starting from the data itself and
then you're going up to generate your
phenotypes and apply it on your cohort
you're not you're not determining rules
you're using decision models to tell you
who which elements are significant
predictors so the method is different if
you look at a little bit in depth how
rule-based phenotyping works is
basically you generate rules typically
by clinical experts they sit together
they decide what defines something that
they're interested in and they are also
responsible for curating databases
generally what a gold standard I might
look like the knowledge engineers then
take those clinical concepts they map
them to the data that exists in the EMR
which is not in a clinically relevant
form just data stored in a database the
process of the generation of the rules
and then testing them you know it's an
iterative process where you keep train
working on your training data set until
you reach a certain specificity and
sensitivity and then you apply it on a
testing data set before you apply it on
the whole cohort or other populations
the the next generation phenotyping is
is used with also the term
high-throughput phenotyping and those
concepts are loosely used in the
literature to determine particular
high-throughput to determine for many
people the the capacity to execute
rule-based or computational forms
phenotyping on the data on large data
and get the results quickly however the
true high-throughput phenotyping is
probably better reserved for the ability
to to generate the phenotypes hundreds
and thousands of them in no time and
minimal time and
the execution large databases for the
outcomes so the actual generation of the
phenotypes when you minimize there all
of the knowledge engineers that's
probably the best best result for what
true high throughput phenotyping is
about in the future we'll probably see
some more sophistication and the
knowledge engineering the top-down
approach where you're starting by
defining the rules that you want and
also the learning from the data so a
combination between a top-down knowledge
engineering and learning from your data
it's probably going to be irrelevant in
the future some of the well-known
challenges that many of us know has to
do with the stages before we even get to
phenotype something out of the data this
has to do with the data standardization
the connection of the data access to the
data having natural language processing
platforms that are capable of being
purposed specific not just generic to
achieve specific goals and then the
actual evolution of EMRs over time
because these things change so those are
well recognized challenges they're also
the actual phenotyping challenges that
has to do with the generation of
features or use features are the
predictors the rules that you want to
use this process is time consuming few
phenotypes can take months if not years
to generate by large large bodies that
are working on this topic right now
queries require maintenance clinical
experts and the knowledge injuries both
have biases once you get the human
element into anything you're introducing
a set of biases that we should try to
investigate features are clinically
irrelevant in automated computational
learning is something that often goes
missing because learning from the data
the data is all treated the same without
necessarily clinical waiting is
something that needs to be kept in mind
and then the validation of those
phenotypes even though it's done that
it's not a uniform process across the
board how to validate it where everybody
agrees to the validation method and then
you there are a variety of of ways how
experts annotate and charge review to
find what gold standards and for those
diseases are so that's also not
something that is uniform across the
board
I'm going to transition now to a case
study that I put together in order to
highlight very important clinical
aspects to the EMR based phenotyping
work so or so this may be very
clinically focused for many of you and I
apologize in advance but this is really
important for the clinicians that are
here as they are trying to put their
first together with information people
and also for the other part of the world
to understand the clinical complexities
of what we're trying to do here so if we
take a look at a 54 year old male with
chronic in disease stage 4 which is a
fairly advanced chronic in disease that
is due to long term diabetes in this
case no other past medical history is
reported he takes lisinopril glipizide
and furosemide he presents to the ER
complaining of coughing and shortness of
breath and subjective fevers the vital
signs are remarkable for mild hypoxemia
and which is the oxygen level in the
blood and the heart rate is elevated to
120 the x-ray revealed bilateral
airspace disease that can be interpreted
as edema which is fluid pneumonia and
infection of the lung and atelectasis
which is a collapse of a part of the
lung some chemistry and blood work were
within normal limits the renal function
was at baseline because it wasn't normal
to begin with troponin and a marker of
the function of the heart is slightly
elevated and so is the BMP another
marker the the patient was started on
antibiotics ceftriaxone as if from
Iceland was given IV form of a you can
call a water pill to help the patient
urinate
it's called furosemide after a few hours
shortness of breath and coughing
resolved and his fast heart rate and
oxygenation also markedly approved that
cardiac marker troponin normalized and
then a subsequent evaluation with an
echo on the heart showed that
was a normal structure and function of
the chambers and valves the mission was
discharged with a prescription for an
antibiotic and a dose adjustment of his
water pill was made to a higher dose so
let's look at the note here for those
who are working on natural language
processing this note here it may look
something like this you may have
pneumonia and then a description of the
course of starting on antibiotics and
then for how long and then factious
workup that went with that description
of the issue with the cardiac marker a
cardiac injury marker and the workup
that was done in that regard and then
the decrease in the oxygen level in the
blood as we mentioned the acute hypoxic
failure was documented and then the use
of water pills and then the FIR ologists
were probably involved in the case to
help because of the volume management
and advanced chronic a disease often
warrants in for ology consultation so
they help with that so this is what the
note might look like for this patient
let's look at the codes that we can
retrieve on this patient after we're
done since we're trying to phenotype
what this patient has so you might get a
combination of the following codes I
don't put the exact numbers and the
labels of the codes just for
simplification purposes but it's
probably going to be along the lines of
the of these elements sepsis
inflammatory response hypoxic restore
failure pneumonia volume overload heart
failure exacerbation non-st elevation
myocardial infarction and pulmonary
edema so how do we finna type this data
we presented the the clinical elements
that what a note looks like then the
codes we can get into the medications
other structured data how do we go about
this well if you're going to take a stab
at this probably going to look something
like this you're probably going to get a
lot of signals for pneumonia there are
codes or medications you can do some NLP
and get that from the notes and there
are some other structure there they can
get as well heart failure sepsis volume
overload myocardial infarction all of
these have what many of us use as
elements to
genotype and determine what this patient
had but in reality what does this
patient really have well let's get into
the case and see what was missing that
we didn't do and go over the first time
the the significance of no other past
medical history was not taken into
account when we did the original
phenotyping and I will get to this in a
little bit as we talk about the
probability that is pre phenotyping
subjective fever was used when the
patient was evaluated and treated a
missing piece that we didn't use perhaps
we didn't know that we should have used
could have been used with natural
language processing is that there was
mild pulmonary vascular congestion on
the patient's x-ray other elements there
was the use of antibiotics another key
element in this case is that after a few
hours the patient symptomatology almost
completely resolved and vital signs of
normality that he had also nearly
normalized we didn't mention what the
patients did in terms of his urination
what he ate and when he drank and what
not so in this case the urine output was
2.5 liters for the nephrologists in the
room the ins-and-outs was negative for
this patient the admission wait which we
didn't use in the phenotyping was up by
10 kilos putting aside issues with
measuring the weight and its accuracy
let's say it's truly a 10 kilos above
the usual weight for this patient and
then we know that the patient was
discharged with an oral antibiotics and
a adjustment of his diuretic so if we
take another deeper look into what
happened here we see that there was a
number of clinically implicit
information that we did not utilize we
did not utilize so the relatively fast
response here to the medical
intervention is key the short course of
antibiotics for pneumonia is also key
it's it's it's it's unusual to treat
pneumonia for five days and it's unusual
for pneumonia to have this fast of a
response these things favor
certain clinical diagnosis that I will
get to in a minute and use clinical
information we talked about the the
urine output of the patient is great on
admission we may have used the
documentation of leg edema as well among
other things that could have been used
and in this case the noisy data that
were introduced as part of structured
and the unstructured data that has to do
with sepsis implementor inflammatory
response and the use of antibiotics in
this case they were all noise if we're
gonna take a deeper look it's gonna it's
not going to look pretty black or white
picture it's gonna be from a clinical
perspective something along what you see
here you start off with the provider
having multiple things on his or her
mind with certain probability that he
has in mind with the fact of advanced
chronic kidney disease and no other past
medical history and the diabetes and
after a set of diagnostics and
therapeutics that list and its
probability and it's likely what gets
adjusted with after you know a few hours
or the next day or two perhaps even
longer but what you're going to see is
that the suspicion for pneumonia is
going to go long through go down
dramatically because the patient nearly
resolved after all the patient's
symptoms quickly improved after a few
hours of medical intervention volume
overload is something that was highly
probable since the patient already has
issues with his kidney disease and then
the presentation that has elements that
are consistent with volume overload
heart failure exacerbation very unlikely
in this case the volume overall symptom
certainly mimics it it looks like it but
a normal echo almost nearly entirely it
rules that out again we the concept of
100% or 0% need to be left out and we're
thinking more of what is the likely and
not likely what is least likely and what
is most likely myocardial infarction
less likely to be a main issue in this
case but the markers were all better up
the patient was at the right agen and
history of long-standing diabetes that
it warranted further intervention
so what you see here is that the most
likely phenotype that the patient should
have was volume overload most likely
related chronic ear disease and all the
other things were least likely or very
improbable nonetheless they were
phenotyped with our usual methodologies
of phenotyping so with this I will
transition to what what what did we just
talk about in this case we talked about
the recording process well there are
multiple processes here we talked about
the providers part of things is
cognitive is behavioral aspects and the
clinical logic by itself all of these
are part of the recording process there
are the whole host of health system
processes that also needs to be
accounted for the EMR systems and their
interactions with the other elements
that eventually gives you the outcome of
the recording process all things that
should be looked at they're clinically
implicit information we're relevant from
the case the missing data sometimes we
think that the data is just missing but
that missingness can be used as a
feature it may be missing because it's
not there but sometimes it's not there
because the provider did not deem it
important enough to be there either
because it's not important or it's
relatively very unimportant to other
things that Trump it's in its importance
the unused data same thing we recognized
that there were a number of unused data
and the case that we presented there
certainly the well-known difficulties
and you know reaching the data that we
need to reach the technological aspect
that needs to be developed more custom
natural language processing all the IT
side of thing to get to the data that we
need to use but we also need to think
that there's data that we should be
using that maybe we just didn't think
that they're usable we should also mimic
as much as possible the clinical process
that ends up with what the phenotype
just like how the patient actually was
diagnosed and treated and incorporating
the concept of certainties as opposed to
just binary does the patient have this
or doesn't have this so that's also
something very important brief you know
typing probability assessment this is
like a Bayesian approach
form decision-making this is relevant to
a lot of medical conditions that we work
with physicians work with it's not
applicable to every single disease but
it's applicable to a lot of diseases so
the the probability of something coming
in even before you do phenotyping is
something that should be looked into not
only the elements that you're using for
your phenotyping so all of these are
phenotypes highlighting the clinical
depth that goes into phenotyping way
beyond just the technological the IT
challenges that many of us or you know
so I'm going to transition here it's
it's a big transition to talk a little
bit about the institutional disease
program and my research in that domain
so medicare covers u.s. citizens who are
65 years of age or older
or if they have incisional disease
regardless of age as long as they
satisfied the work history requirement
it's a highly organised program frequent
data are collected from outpatient units
in all the country the the system has
near complete inclusion of all people
who have incisional disease and our own
dialysis so that is a big cohort the
limitations that we know on the United
States renal disease system that is well
documented is that there's lack of
continuous validation of methods lack of
complete comorbidity and other labs
acquisition at the time of registration
there's some other inaccuracies that
we'll get into but there's a significant
issues with the data so why doesn't
central disease matter
well let's took a look at the numbers
here the five-year survival is forty
percent meaning if you are on here and
on hemodialysis sixty percent of people
die within the first five years that is
that puts it somewhere between lung
cancer and colon cancer the cost we have
over 650,000 patients who are on
dialysis
these patients represent 7% I'm sorry
less than 1% of the total Medicare
beneficiaries but the cost is close to
7% of the total Medicare budget so a
very small portion of Medicare
beneficiaries taking a big portion of
the budget if you look at the trajectory
of the cost
ESRD cost is about 31 billion this is
based on the most recent annual data
report of 2015 they report up to 2013
there's a two-year gap so this is the
most fresh data and the cost is 31
billion well if you look at the NIH all
spending on research that's 32 billion
and it's getting there so getting into
the background of my research work the
medical evidence report also called as
form 27 28 is the form where it gets
filled to register people with Medicare
in order to receive benefits it's very
similar to disability forms for people
who are not nephrologists here you need
to report certain demographics certain
labs certain comorbidities I will show
us the the coma really section in a
minute and I will tell you how the data
is is reflected in the u.s. RDS and the
research that is done half of that data
in a minute one of the things that we
already know is that 23% of albumin
values a very simple structured data to
report is missing there are
uncertainties about the documentation of
that cause of institutional disease the
reason the patient ended up on dialysis
as captured by that form there are
significant uncertainties that that was
documented by researchers to take this
to another level of depth there were the
agreement on the biopsy reports of
kidney biopsies and what the
documentation of what the biopsy
findings for gulimero nephritis a type
of inflammation of the kidney the
agreement was only 23 percent
and we don't know how much of the 23% is
due to chance but it's very low even if
it's not due to chance the agreement
between claims data and the nephrology
care that is documented on that form
it's 48 percent with an agreement that
is beyond a chance of 0.2 9 which is
below agreement fair at best agreement
between the prescription record for
erythropoietin use which is a type of
medicine to help with not having enough
red blood cells in the body the
agreement was only 57% based on this VA
study and the capo is 0.41 the agreement
on nursing home use was a recall of 33%
and precision of 8% which tells you that
the sensitivity of the capturing itself
is not enough but when it's when when
when it's reported appropriately then
that tends to be more accurate so the
hypothesis of my research is that the
reporting of comorbidities on the form
and I'll show you the form in a minute
using phenotyping algorithms is more is
going to capture more comorbidities and
potentially be more reflective of the
patient's through disease State the
methods that we use this is what
observational retrospective work we we
took the we defined the court as
everybody who started chronic dialysis
at outpatient dialysis facilities that
belong to Indiana University Health
between 2005 through 2014 the reason for
choosing 2005 is that the dates they
rolled out the most recent form to
register patients for for Medicare
benefits for dialysis so we started with
that date we excluded people who had the
older version after 2005 and people who
had unreadable elements were also
excluded the data sources that we used
we actually got the paper copies of all
those registration forms we got through
the Indiana Network for patient care
which is part of the health exchange
network that we have at Indiana to get
all the data from all the systems not
only the local ones
downtown Indianapolis but all
metropolitan Indianapolis we we got the
data for up to 10 years and we'll get to
that in a minute and we used crown web
which is a platform that report it has
multiple purposes but the data that we
got out of it was the chronological
history of Institutional disease tells
you where each patient dialyzed for how
long and then if they transferred and or
or got a kidney transplant and they
maybe they failed and went back to the
Alyce's down the road so all of that
chronological history was captured here
because it's relevant for the
calculation of mortality down the road
so this is the form that i argot adhere
and there are about 23 comorbidities
total here the ones that are highlighted
are the ones that I chose mainly because
we had the semi functional rule based
phenotypes or the existing that I was
able to use modify adjust for my purpose
and then implement as you can tell here
the requirement is to get as much as
possible off of the last ten years of of
that patient life before the onset of
end-stage renal disease diagnosis the
methods that we used we used some of the
usual structural elements billing codes
medications and laboratory data and for
certain diagnosis some other
miscellaneous elements we use natural
language processing for in ability to
ambulate
and we used a proxy of wheelchair use
for this purpose and created a Likert
scale with the most likely that the
patient was you know in ambulating
versus more likely versus least likely
we used some skill testing for
comparisons down the road Macomb our
test for disagreement t-test and the
standard a mortality ratio calculation
was based on models that we got from the
kidney epidemiology and cost Center that
is part of the University of Michigan
that is contracted with CMS to do some
of the analytical work go ahead before I
lost a thought how many did you require
that there were a certain number of
encounters or longitudinal data
about was there any requirement ten
years worth of ten years is the duration
of all the data that is that the person
filling the form for the comb or a key
section it's expected to be the
nephrologist it's expected to go back
ten years to get all the data that is
needed to complete that section they're
thinking about you're missing this piece
and you could have patients that have a
lot of encounters in that like a lot of
data and then you get a patient where
there is data that goes back ten years
but it's very sparse and it actually
especially related the ambulatory piece
related so I'm just wondering if there
was any restriction on that the the well
Medicare does not care about that they
want you to fill it and Accord in your
in the way that you processed it
oh the AMR data yes so when they say you
need to go back ten years they don't
tell you you need to go to as many air
Mars as possible they don't tell you you
can only use your own system they will
tell you get everything that is needed
to complete it is that answer the
question no you're doing a comparison
between two different datasets two
different sources of data to see if they
have a consistent result correct one of
which is the Medicare form one of which
is the EMR data the EMR data could be
just one encounter it could be a hundred
encounters how do you differentiate
between the two I'll get to that
question in a little bit when we dissect
why there was differences I'll get to
that in a little bit
the percentage agreement between the
providers and the phenotypes are
demonstrated in this table the
comorbidities are on the Left anything
that says computer positive means it was
flagged by the phenotype as this
condition is present when it says
negative it means it's it's not present
or it's just that it's not flagged as
positive it might be simply unknown
because of possible missing data MD
positive means that the box on this form
here was checked negative may mean it's
absent but may mean it's unknown as well
so it's hard to tease out that
possibility for the negative for the
unchecked box
so for example if we look at here this
one this 30% here for congestive heart
failure
the computers phenotyping said that it's
positive for 30% of people when the
physicians said that it's not present
and these are all the four possibility
for all that 2x2 possibilities these are
all the proof for all these diagnoses
all of them were statistically
significant significant difference
between the two methodologies so now
we're going to get to answer some of
those questions which is well which data
sources are we using which data sources
the physicians are using are they using
the same data sources well with a health
exchange network we can use a big broad
of data for as long as you want
so there's access questions about which
data sources were used there's the time
question that the providers actually go
back even whether they're local you know
am ours did they go back 10 years to
document that minor stroke that happened
nine years prior for which the patient
had no residual neurological function
and document in a different system
perhaps or just fell off even if it's in
the same system so there's a time
question there's the scope of access
local versus more remote systems and
then there's a question which is even if
those two are the same while are the
phenotypes just more captioning or just
triggered so easily whereas the
physician may have more specific logic
to his way of interpreting the data that
is not represented by the phenotypes all
possibilities there might be more
possibilities but those are the ones
that we try to address so we narrowed
down the source of the data to the local
sources only and we did this on multiple
iterations we did you know we started
with 10 years which is what is expected
but then to understand the differences
we came down to eight years seven years
five years three years and down to one
year we also narrow down all the
earmarks from being everything there is
metropolitan Indianapolis to only the
EMR czar in the local system the
downtown system which the nephrologist
are using for outpatient are you so we
tried different
combination of these I'm showing you
only the what you may call the worst
case scenario
meaning just one year and only that your
local EMR you'll see that many of these
comorbidities are not systole
significant anymore
meaning that time and access explained
why they were significant before but
some of them are still significant and
still poses a question why is there a
difference and what we get out of this
is the next step well does it doesn't
matter so when we looked at the
comorbidity index and plugged it into
the model that calculate at the end the
expected death for that patient and then
plugged in the actual death for the
patient and the group of dialysis
patients the actual death doesn't change
the same we know this the expected death
was changed and then the standard I'm
will child to ratio was different
between the two and I'll show you that
in a minute
the standard i mortality ratio just a
quick background when it's 1.2 it means
that your unit has 20% more deaths than
the expected average there are
standardized mortality ratio there are
nationals and you know by States and etc
but but the concept is when it's above 1
that means you are you're your patients
are dying more than the average and it's
less than 1 your patients are surviving
better than average so it's it looks
better if your SMR is below 1 there are
other standardized metrics that we don't
need to spend much time on right now but
as with hospitalizations transfusion
ratios right now the standardized
metrics are not incorporated directly in
any payment implications but that may
change very soon the main a payment
adjustment is the quality incentive
program pay payment which which take
multiple multiple quality measures that
has to do with the patient's labs their
modification of calcium phosphorus and
PTH and blood pressure and other things
but right now those standardized metrics
are not incorporated and that payment
readjustment model so let's look at the
standardized mortality ratio
using the phenotypes with the eventual
expected death that comes out of that
versus what is off of the paper copies
of those registration forms that were
filled by by the providers we looked at
years 2009 through 2014 we started from
2009 because the kidney epidemiology and
cost center did not have interactive
models that we can use right away it was
just built in for their own internal use
prior to 2009 I wasn't able to get a
hold of anything that I can use with my
research team so we started from 2009
but what you can see is that for all
these years there are a statistically
significant difference between the
standardized mortality ratio calculated
differently by the two methods and then
the next question is well which one is
the right one is it the phenotypes by
the computer algorithms the rule-based
ones or is it what the physicians
reported on the form so we formed a
nephrologist panel out of four people we
determined an agreement is when three
out of the four at least three out of
the four agree on the output of those
phenotypes and we sampled all the cohort
and and these are the comorbidities so
you will see that there was agreement
between the panel and the phenotypes on
many of these it's exceptionally perfect
for reasons that I don't fully
understand on cancer strokes and
substance abuse
maybe because these are the structured
data that are used are just so unique
they're not like the noisiness and in
them is not as as as significant as for
other comorbidities but what stands out
here is COPD and CHF chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease and congestive heart
failure the agreement was a towing cost
essentially with what was reported on
between that the panel and the
phenotyping so the nephrologist were
disagreeing 53% of the time with what
the phenotype said so the phenotype said
it's positive in the nephrologist said
no it's not positive
the COPD 47% of that time where the
phenotype said it's positive the
physician said no it's not then no it's
not was either a direct no or we need
more data so we combined these together
in determining that what constitute a
disagreement so what do we get out of
this well we saw that true based
phenotypes were superior to my manual
form completion for many comorbidities
as judged by a gold standard of a
neurologist panel we can talk about the
nephrology panel itself as a gold
standard since we earlier have mentioned
that there's no gold standard for what
constitutes the best gold standard
anyway but by judging by that panel they
decided that there was superiority to
the rule based phenotype as opposed to
the manual completion by the providers
we saw that time going back as long as
10 years or going to a broader scope
changes the outcome of the phenotype and
and gets closer to explain so to explain
what was reported on the forms so when
they were matched when we narrowed it
down that that suggests that the
provider looked for up for close to one
year using local sources when the
phenotype is not different from what was
reported but it remained positive for
many other comorbidities we saw that the
SMR was lowered reflecting the higher
expected death and we saw that COPD and
CHF using the usual phenotyping elements
both had caveats that were significant
and were not felt appropriate by the
physicians by the nephrologist the
plausible explanation
that is to be tested is that both heart
failure and COPD in non dialysis
population can be as the diagnosis can
be reasonably made
on clinical grounds and we think that
the fact that incisional disease
population are prone to recurrent
episodes of volume overload potentially
mimicking the symptomatology of heart
failure and COPD that might explain why
there were disagreement on this and they
were picked up so significantly by the
phenotypes which tells me the phenotypes
needs further adjustment to cope with
the in stage renal disease population
main limitation is sample size we about
we had the 300 people only and the
generalizability is definitely an issue
the next step so that was the first part
that's just testing out phenotyping and
the physician is reporting so we wanted
to take that to another level we wanted
to see is that annotation I'm going to
use the word annotation from this point
on to reflect that behavior with which
the provider was deciding to check the
box of each comorbidity or keep it
unchecked so if we set that annotation
irrespective of its true reflectiveness
of the true state of the patient as a
target to do machine learning on to see
the consistency is it predictable we
thought that if that is predictable
meaning if you if a 1c for example is
used consistently across the board to
determine if diabetes is present that
will come up high in your machine
learning approach because that's going
to be consistent it's gonna be a high
feature whereas and I'm giving an
example of a reflection of phrase here
so if you have a smooth surface and all
the data is coming in and being
reflected consistently systematically
the reflection will be in one direction
whereas on the right side with an uneven
surface that reflects a more
heterogeneous inconsistent behavior the
Rays will go in different directions
when you're getting the same data so we
we wanted to see what the predictability
of that annotation is like and so we did
for the set for the my second research
project which we just submitted to a Mia
study of the predictability of the
physicians annotations on those forms so
we got all the data
the labs the medications all the
structured data from the IM PC you put
in a master datasets we got all their
labs and discretized those labs based on
built-in filters with the software that
we use that basically Kat creates out of
the continuous laboratory data that we
have into categorical variable that are
easier to use we use different feature
subsets we use different decision models
we used a an amplification method that's
called Smoot part of the end of this in
the different decision models that we
use and then we looked at the different
metrics for the evaluation of those
predictive models precision like I said
is the positive predictive value recall
is the sensitivity the F measure is a
composite of the two and the ROC so what
does that show this is what shows on the
left column you have each outcome the
best performing algorithm is the second
one MB is for naive Bayes SL is simple
logistic the class is positive and
negative positive means those are the
ones that were checked on the form
negative means that was unchecked
precision recall and F measure and the
ROC what I want you to look at out of
this very heavy table here is the
positive one because there are a lot of
issues with the negative one what does
it mean that the box was unchecked let's
look at the positive for now and see
what that means
we saw that you if you look at here scan
all of these quickly you'll see for
example for coronary artery disease the
precision was 0.7 the recall is 0.67 the
F measure was 0.7 generally speaking and
we considered good prediction when the F
measure is above 0.8 but that's not the
whole story
some of these might be perceived to be
reasonably predictive but many of them
are not but let's take a deeper look
into this these graphs here the top row
is the precision the second row is the
recall each column is a comorbidity so
on the Left column
coronary artery disease precision and
recall cancer precision and recall COPD
and sand and strokes you'll see a few
things here you'll see that there is a
very big difference in the performance
of each decision model compared to the
other decision models you'll see that
some of the decision models did not
perform at all like random forest in
this example as you can see here this is
zero percent this is 100 percent so the
best prediction is going to be close to
1.0 no prediction whatsoever is 0% and
these is the performances across the
different feature subsets meaning you're
telling the decision model how many
features to get from all the set of the
data that we fed the machine learning
algorithms this is for the other four
with this on 8 outcomes this heart
failure diabetes / full vascular disease
and retinopathy again not a great
prediction very variable prediction the
poor data predictive that we can get out
of this for the provider annotation
suggests that there might be a
heterogeneous behavior to to check that
box or leave it unchecked the provider
annotations we know from the previous
study may not necessarily reflect the
tuesday's but certainly this data
support that suggestion as well and then
we thought that the use of machine
learning can be used as an effective
tool to study the behavioral aspect for
those you can call them
naturally-occurring
annotations usually we think of
annotations in the world of phenotyping
as you know part of the research team
they're synced together they have data
said they need to determine positive or
negative so you can you can test your
phenotype algorithms on or your machine
learning but what we're looking at here
is that phenotyping that happened that
annotation that happened that is not
intervened on that it's not part of your
research you are
predicting something that's already
annotated so that was a very useful
piece of machine learning that can be
used and so the next step is can we
decide design a clinical decision
support system with phenotyping ability
based on this data that we just showed
there there might be a very well
reasonable role for such a system can
phenotyping predict mortality and other
clinical outcomes certainly mortality is
one of the big ones we just talked about
the SRD mortality and cost issues with
the data clinical decision support with
phenotyping may fit in just nicely for
that sort of goal research goal can we
design a perspective trial to set out on
a bigger sample bigger cohorts multiple
centers and ultimately can that lead to
well design predictive models where we
can actually know what to intervene on
where we can reduce the actual mortality
for ESRD patients and I'll leave it to
you thank you questions yes sir
excellent talk and every time I hear
talks you give a very good talk but
every time I hear things like this I get
really depressed about well what we're
up against in informatics but that said
so clearly part of the problem is this
form in that you know people who are
completing it are you know what they're
probably just checking off really
quickly in in your kind of conversations
with your expert panel does it give you
any ideas of how you might improve the
data on the form so that the database
that you're accessing could have more
accurate data yeah so so first of all
when I sort of off-the-record talked to
some with a nephrologist say hey are you
really feeling that section very few
admitted that they just go off why what
the other clerks in the unit gave them
which is usually the last couple
discharge summaries and why not to fill
the form sometimes they just they
actually go and check it for them and
they just sign at the bottom there are
certainly some issues with with with is
this fully reflective of the physicians
annotation behavior or checking the box
but but the concept of going back ten
years of data and being very able and
actually should backtrack a little bit
the person the nephrologist who fills
the form is not the nephrologist who was
involved not necessarily the
nephrologist that was involved in the PS
or you care it might be in a unit that
does not have the connectivity to all
the EMR systems it may be somebody who
doesn't know anything about the patient
and just gets the last couple discharge
summaries so there are certainly issues
with that not just if the the physician
actually dedicated the time but what I'm
what I'm proposing is that what is
required to go up to ten years and the
possibility of so many EMR systems even
within one city and the the fact that
physicians can go from multiple systems
those are very challenging aspects even
for the very motivated nephrologists so
I'm gonna we need to link to understand
that what is required is very
challenging to begin with even for the
motivator ones so ask questions but just
one quick follow-up did the forum's ever
get updated or does the forum just get
completed once when maybe you develop
renal failure an excellent question no
they're not updated they're used only
once only initially so if the patient
you know two years down there es Rd
course on dialysis get diagnosed with
metastatic lung cancer and died a few
months afterwards that is not captured
that is not reflected the mortality is
captured and will be part of the us RDS
you know data I don't know what the the
degree with which they are able to to
get to that sort of data so they're
aware of such things but right now
there's only that initial one that
determines the comorbidity burden of the
patient and does not get changed down
the road
excellent question yes sir
you know very very thought-provoking
presentation so really appreciate it one
thing I didn't get is are using natural
language understanding of physicians
notes discharge summaries and histories
and physicals or was that not included
in your model for the first part of the
study where we did the natural language
processing that was for inability to
ambulate because there was effectively
no structured elements that were that
can capture that as a condition so
that's what we use natural language
processing it methoxy of using
wheelchair was the likelihood of that to
reflect innovation ambulate for the
second part which is the machine
learning approach we didn't use natural
language we didn't use any structured
elements that were the result of natural
language processing because one of the
things that it would be helpful to look
at is the motivation for each of those
structured data elements so if you look
at coding from a coders perspective you
know those are notoriously inaccurate
because the coders are coding for a
reimbursement so anything that hints
have congestive heart failure they get
input can justify I feel whether there's
evidence for it or not on the other hand
for the discharge summary the physician
is interested in accuracy and so that I
would submit is probably going to be the
most accurate I agree it'll be more
accurate for sure right what I presented
in the case was that even what what is
documented by the physician can be very
noisy and inaccurate because of the
timing of which notes you're capturing
and and then there's a whole different
layers of you know the the physician
their hierarchy and the medical
establishments are they you know interns
at 1:00 a.m.
writing a note or are they an attending
at 10:00 a.m. the next day
so those differences may play out a
little bit but certainly the challenge
of the billing codes and there are noise
and inaccuracies well recognized
going a bit further to what what I'm
what I'm proposing is that even what
it's documented by the physician can and
should be questioned yes well very good
talk thank you but there's a lot of
research that says that when providers
are filling out the forms they do to
support the plan they already have in
mind so for example if I wanted to give
somebody Social Security benefits I
would try and rationalize that then
lipoma I filled out mm-hmm given that
for example drug addiction is a reason
for this qualification for Social
Security benefits how would that affect
the accuracy of this form relative to
yeah
BMR yeah that's a good question right
now I my my my sense of this is that
because there's not a whole lot of
incentive to make this form as accurate
as possible at the individual provider
level it's not playing it's not it's
probably not playing the role that you
just described but maybe down the road
if you know the implications on what's
documented and reported it's going to
translate the payments or why not I mean
I'm sad to say this but if if it's going
to be part of you know people's payments
then they will pay more attention to it
and introduce some of the biases that
you just described but you don't think
there's a bias in the treatment I want
for the patient it's a determining of
the comorbidities right now the bias is
more we just don't have time and energy
to invest in it but the bias that might
happen down the road if it's part of the
payment is to perhaps over report things
which would be a whole different
spectrum of asking the question here
we'll dealing more with under reporting
and some inaccuracies but down the road
when it's part of the payment there
might be that possible bias I mean that
that is we're already seeing that with
the Medicare review programs where
they're sending out
and respect issues to review cases and
try an up code for the insurance
companies yes it's not necessary yet
probably to do that for this purpose not
yet anyway yes maybe I don't want that
it's interesting that where you saw if
I'm interpreting correctly the best
concordance with some of the things that
as a nephrologist might be front and
center for example recalling that a
patient had cancer which would make them
ineligible for a transplant or recalling
that someone was a drug user since that
has implications for transplant as well
yeah that's a very good point sometimes
we have to end to ask ourselves those
questions when we're trying to determine
the patient's getting a kidney
transplant and I can easily see how that
can evolve in an actual ethical you know
did this person smoke their last
cigarette you know or their last drink
is just five months prior and they could
really use being on a transplant list
right now so that those are certainly
some of the issues that we deal with did
i miss mr. eager dad I thought that or
we had the high concordance was between
the EMR and the reviewer okay is that
for example you look at the EMR same as
drug addiction and when the panel to
frolic us who independently read it not
the person who filled out the form they
had a very high concordance and that's
something that's going to be pretty much
cut and dried based upon what's in the
EMR it's serious yes I'm gonna get a
positive UDS or I'm gonna take negative
UDS so therefore I could make that
decision the difference comes in you
know for example smoking we interpret
smoking date of EMRs horrible terrible
the concordance part was indeed for the
computer algorithms phenotypes with what
the physician panel but if I understood
you correctly you are referring to the
biases based on your last quest
here which was you know the the
over-reporting or the underreporting
so when you're determining somebody's
eligibility you're asking yourself how
rigidly those criteria for transplant
are followed by the nephrologists if I
understood you correctly but did you
find that there was a higher concordance
than between the EMR and the form for
those for cancer for cancer yes okay and
for drug addiction
no no between the panel no no we go back
to that there was I mean the statistical
difference was for all of the cases when
we used all mature Politan Indianapolis
and and ten years worth of data that was
across the board this is the so there
was certainly more capturing by the
phenotypes the EMR based ones compared
to the forms so you're treating
nephrologists you fill out the form had
a very poor concordance with the EMR
correct your panel of reviewers had a
very high concordance with the so
patients had cancer and it wasn't
reported on their forms that they did
I'm not actually going to ask a question
about data quality I was already
interested in some of your early slides
where you talked about different degrees
of certainty and the idea of weighing
evidence so moving away potentially from
just a binary decision of yes there's
this diagnosis or no there is not this
diagnosis and I was wondering if that's
something that you're planning on
looking at more going forward
incorporating into your work yes
it's very challenging though because
we're starting off by how do we even get
the pre phenotyping probabilities of
things and for certain diseases there's
some literature but for the most part
there's no such
and that goes into you know the the art
of practicing medicine we go in with our
you know we even before seeing the
patients we have an idea based on their
age their initial presentation about
what differential diagnosis we need to
be thinking of not so much necessarily
in a you know purely probabilistic
manner in the sense that all pneumonia
is lighted it's likely what is 20% but
at least in a rank order where or a
relative order if you will across all
the diagnoses there on your differential
diagnosis and then that get that justice
so the concept of that relativity is
something that can be worked on and
should be done I don't know that we will
get to the point where we will be
assigning actual pre phenotyping
probabilities because that doesn't exist
even for the practicing physician
you